I was handing this Jeep Perico and you
could catch me on the bootleg calf
podcast right now tune in right right
now Enterprise
the podcast we have a special guest in
here
his gangster girls drops Friday
gangster grills
G Perico
welcome first of all
things are going uh very well as I see
you have a brand new necklace that is uh
massive compared to previous Enterprise
click chains yeah my the last one is
like just one of these letters
yeah
that's why I did it people was giving me
[__] about
I'm usually good at drowning out outside
noise but like I was getting roasted for
my you know because it was too small
yeah
yeah I usually I was getting roasted for
uh
for my piece you know I was just keeping
it modest on the grind so let me just
how much was this
um
it was a it was a nice it was a pretty
penny north of 50.
yeah wow you know you you strike me as
the kind of guy who doesn't do stupid
things with your money outside of buy
cars because you do have a car problem
yeah I definitely have a uh I was just
talking to my business manager I wanted
to get a uh Maybach the other day
and she like nah you just bought the
necklace hold down this was already
coming okay okay okay yeah how many cars
you have now uh
uh I'm low right now I didn't did a lot
of uh flip totaling out some [__] Jesus
is it safe to say you're a bad driver
who loves cars because I'm a bad driver
I just don't like cars yeah I'm not the
best driver
but it is exciting to ride with me
though that's one thing I could say is
it dangerous
no no no no no no no I mean the worst
thing that happened with me my lip my
tooth went through my lip and [__]
that's not too bad it's pretty bad yeah
yeah so are you currently allowed to
drive technically no
um
so I don't drive right you don't drive
yeah the homies are off so who's uh you
don't you can't even get car insurance
if you want it huh I got an insurance
in your name yeah oh I got an insurance
don't they usually like because how many
points are on your license
I'm I think I'm gonna point away from
just being like [__] up for a while
but I've been good all year so I'm
actually getting everything situated
this upcoming week so we gotta I'm gonna
be back good by Golden you've been
dropping a lot
I wouldn't say that man I feel like I
kind of like no I mean I just feel like
you've been applying like non-stop
pressure man like
it's uh it's moderate
it's pretty you know it's it's nice it's
moderate we're gonna get heavy though
we're getting Heavy after this well
that's what I keep hearing right I keep
hearing that you have like this body of
work that you're working on that's like
the real album yeah some crazy singles
you got crazy features
but you've been just throwing out kind
of like these projects yeah independent
you do what you want now you know right
right so the end of the year I'm working
on a like that project
that's like that thing that's gonna be
timeless not for the time you know what
I mean so I've been I've been working on
that for a minute
um I've heard some names that are
supposed to be on that project
yeah it's a fuel it's a few good yeah
it's a Few Good Men on there I heard you
got some damn you got some big names on
there some big features yeah it's a feel
good man it's a care to share it's
feeling good
uh when it's time
okay because I know when it's time we'll
drop the bomb for sure how did the uh
gangster girls thing happen
um like cheesy so like my guy Lake yeah
Lake shazy 2021
when I uh
just like got made my mind up and got
focused and started doing it it like
just start connecting immediately on the
Underground and um like cheesy have been
hollering at me and I had it was a few
like L.A Summers 2 was supposed to be a
gangster grills but I just didn't feel
like
I wanted it to be a like I wanted to be
a gangster girls when I make a gangster
Grill so I wanted to feel like a mixtape
but like an album at the same time so
that's what this hot shot is but the
conversation been going on for a year
and the crazy thing is
um you know Lake reached out to me you
know usually it's people like man I need
a gangster girls dying for it and it's
always been a goal of mine because when
I was growing up Gangster grills was
that [__] of course that's all you heard
so like this is definitely something off
the bucket list and um you know uh Lake
was hitting me but I didn't really think
nothing of it I'm like I'm just thinking
he's saluting hey we should do a project
right and you know how to enter well
like ain't an industry [__] not at all
working in the industry yeah for sure
but you know how a lot of people just be
like hey let's work let's do something
that never happens so I didn't really um
like really just take it too serious and
then I was in um I'm in [__] Vegas
taking my daughter I took my daughter
shopping I'm in the Aria and um
I'm running down to what's that Javier's
yeah Javier is a Mexican spotted so I'm
upstairs in the room tired just tore it
down for my daughter and um I'm like I'm
hungry I ain't ate [__] all day I rushed
down to Javier's
to see if the kitchen is still open
um somebody yanked my arm I'm like who
the [__] is this it's uh lb cousin I go
to the back lb and them runs lb yeah it
runs jokes up man they got the whole
back of the restaurant sold up right so
I sit and I ain't even have to order
[__] it's food everywhere I'm eating
and um I met this guy named Rob Liddy he
owned a company called Liddy he like
what you doing pay me to do a private
party like and it was like a
like damn near more than what I get paid
for a lot of shows I only did two verses
but
Jeezy was also performing there and
um gz camera guy I know him from going
to uh
to uh drama in them studio and [__]
right and he's like man what's up when
that gangster girl is coming out
that's what he tell me and I'm like
gangster girls what you mean and he like
yeah drama and Lake been talking about
it I said oh this [__] is serious right
so that's when I'm like yeah let's get
this [__] done and um did you have do
you don't have to pay drama for that uh
it's love it's love
it's love we definitely gave up a few
dollars but nothing nowhere to what it
was just like the money I gave him was
just a token of my appreciation thank
you yeah yeah but it was like what he
get like it was like not even a [__]
attempt for that [__] right so
um did Lake try to sign you to
generation now
um nah we never had a conversation like
that but you know I got to full support
and all that so but it is you know
something a possibility scheme for a
while you know yeah yeah it's definitely
a possibility but
um I'm just man I'm enjoying um Empire
when Perico's Enterprise like yep I'm
[__] like in the best position I ever
been like Fame wise
is uh whatever but like you know
financials and the [__] that I could do
and the type of different business calls
I'm getting especially with this thing
where everybody's selling catalog and
[__] yeah I've been getting these like
no [__] no exaggeration I've been
getting like multi-million dollar offers
for your catalog yeah
and it's like
I feel like I ain't even hit that
[__] Peak or got to a place where we
invested because I haven't spent no
money on marketing or anything at all
yet yeah because how okay so since
leaving Rock Nation
how many projects have you dropped with
Empire because it's been
two and a half three years now
I've been two years exactly well two
years in a month exactly in those in
that time how many projects do you um I
think we had like 15 or something like
that Jesus so the multi-million dollar
deal is for those 15. nah it's just for
uh or for your 2021. it was just for the
catalog so all the [__] I did in 2021
did you turn it down
um yeah yeah
respectfully you know and then you know
if it's the opportunity is still there
we'll Circle back around but are you
like you could be like yeah [__] 2021
take that take the bread and then you
know just run it up in 2022 in 2023 and
nah for sure for sure it's a um
is like a a great feeling to know that
that's there and also like it got me
looking at the board a little bit
different and setting goals a little bit
different because it's like like I said
I haven't spent any money on marketing
right so I got money let me invest some
money in marketing and some of this old
[__] because it's really not that old
people got songs that's three years old
to [__] around and go viral and catch
for sure it's been happening all the
time yeah so let me put a um now it's
like let me put some effort into
marketing this old [__] while I'm still
dropping some new [__] because I feel
like I I haven't maxed out the situation
it's like if I could get that then you
know why not try to get [__] 15 20
million
um do you feel like you could ever
do the major label thing because you've
been so like I feel like you've been
thriving on being under empire being in
a situation where you call your shots
you could drop it anytime you want yeah
uh the major the major thing isn't for
me just how just the type of person that
I am and how I grew up like bro I got
like a serious problem with authority
you know what I mean and when you put
yourself in a major situation it worked
for every it worked for different people
right so everybody thing is different
but for me specifically I hate having to
go
explain why my record is tight and why
it might work and why it's necessary
when it's clearly this is what I'm in
the building for for what I do you know
what I mean so I don't think the major
thing is my it's not my cup of tea at
all because even before I signed they
was giving me a hundred grand for a
project for each project and I was just
coming out you know I mean is because I
understand business and the hustle right
so I had
what I realized when I signed the Rock
Nation already had everything that a
label got besides radio I already had my
own digital marketing team I already
have my own PR right and then I got you
know I'm the Strategic partner so it's
like I pretty much got like the meat and
bones of what a label did because all I
did was sign and um
you know that's another story but yeah I
never I never signed to a major ever
pretty much they're just giving you an
advance at that point it's like I'm
signing for an advance and radio play
that never happened right and I'm in it
I'm not in it for the fame like I'm in
it because I like to make music but I
love to hustle and be able to do I love
to be active and I love challenges and
[__] so like I don't want to put myself
in another situation where the challenge
is me just getting music put out and
then if the [__] don't perform highly
expected then everybody moving on to the
[__] other hundred thousand artists
that's out [__] that
like I'm in it like crazy I was gonna
say like like you're obviously famous
right you're not like a superstar but
like you know amongst the West Coast
hip-hop
world you are one of them ones you know
what I mean yes but pretty much any City
I hit somebody gonna notice me and [__]
right but I do feel like a lot of
artists they get into this [__] and they
focus on the wrong [__] which is like
being famous or oh man the look
academics ain't post me or all that type
of [__] and it's like I feel like you're
doing so much better than a lot of these
guys because you kind of are approaching
the game from a whole different
perspective like
you're putting your money in the right
[__] you're like using the music as a
vehicle to set up like long-term wealth
you know what I'm saying exactly I'm in
it for the long game because that's
where that's where the money is at in
the long game and I think a lot of
artists
got like this Cinderella
idealism in their head which it also
stemmed from the streets think about it
in the streets I'm broke one day I [__]
around and hit a lick and then I'm up
shining the next day you know I mean now
like business business don't work like
that you got to put in the footwork and
and really grind it out so a lot of
people do it to get that advanced and to
get [__] like this in this and then be
broke and then and then and get to
complaining about a situation that they
took so you signed it's like yo you
complaining but you signed the paperwork
right you know what I mean
um for you man like I know you uh you
and uh D smoke uh partnered up in bought
Broadway gym D shmoke
um I've heard you've been doing other
stuff in the real estate game yeah yeah
I just got a house new crib yeah are you
doing anything uh are you just
everything like all this [__] for me to
move in just got finished so all the
little work that I had to do and [__] so
I'm feeling good about that I was gonna
say are you like diving in pretty pretty
tough on the real estate into terms of
just like investing no I ain't gonna sit
here in front like that but if an
opportunity present itself right and
then at the time if I got the the liquid
to do it then I'll do it but um I'm
really just focused on on music Club
just getting my brand together and
content I want to get into these movies
hey for real you think you could act I
definitely can act I did a few roles and
[__]
um you know the movie [__] it's this
term that got called hurry up and wait
so I didn't shot some [__] like a year
ago something two years ago they still
ain't releasing yeah like to be [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah well one of them is
like an actual feature film oh fire yeah
you think you're they're gonna Typecast
you
I'm pretty Typecast but it's like some
19 so I think I spoke on them before on
here I'm like it's in the 70s when
hip-hop first started
so I'm like a [__]
like a gangster security do they have to
cover your your tats up yeah they make
up me down
what's that like like seeing yourself
without tattoos for like a couple of
days
that [__] is dope like I'm gonna I
actually want to get some of this [__]
removed but I just got something on my
face
which the you know the ideal behind that
is I'm building this company up to sell
it for 100 million so when I get that
check I'm getting this [__] removed the
blue t-shirt mm-hmm
which which tattoo would you get removed
first
um by the way that [__] hurts
I don't know I gotta I like I got a lot
of [__] like I was like a scratch paper
at one time letting my homies practice
on me and [__] so you're a BG tattoo how
painful was that because it's like all
just dark ink
um it actually wasn't that painful
because the only thing that I remember
that always stand out is when you start
getting under the armpit I'm like bro
don't worry about that they ain't gonna
see you under my [__] anyway that [__]
hurts yeah it's like kind of like the
places you can see that usually hurt the
most yeah yeah that's yeah I have a few
tattoos in
like right here that [__] hurt yeah I
want to get a few more like at first it
was like damn I want to act but now with
this makeup [__] and Technology I'm good
I wanted to I actually wanted to get
permanent gold teeth right I've been
wanting to do that since I was like 15.
and um it's like I want it that's one
thing that's definitely you still want
to do that yeah but don't do that bro
but it's going to be difficult you know
getting roles because I would love to
[__] do some [__] like iced tea play
a [__] cop or just kidding just get
the joint you popping and you pop out
yeah yeah yeah
yeah get this the all right listen I
don't know anybody who got permanents
that are like that breath don't smell
like [__] all their breath stinks and
nobody actually feels like it was a good
idea like two years later right you
gotta brush your teeth like like it like
it's just so much it's just it's a lot
of Maintenance yeah it's a lot of
[__] maintenance you could go to
Mexico and get that [__] though done for
the low ski for sure let's go to TJ I
don't want to come back with no big
horse gold teeth though
you look like A.D but we'll go see
hey you got them Chompers hey I got my
teeth my teeth blew out right but it's
like
I feel like
if I get like a perfect set of whites it
kind of steal from the characteristics
of my [__] you know yeah
yeah it would look like yeah I like the
Crooked ship tooth Brown tooth smile
[__] it I'm thugging it is what I didn't
live the life that lets you know some
[__] didn't happen I love it
um so no features on the gangster girls
um no actually I got a hook from RJ okay
I got a hug from RJ but outside of that
like my you know I love taking projects
to the face man because I I record at
the crib or at my office and it's just
like
you know super comfortable I think
that's why it just come out so much it's
like I'm not in the pressure like I'm in
a 12 hour session I gotta hurry up and
do this like I get to ride around listen
to Beats rap [__] in my voice memo
come home request do my other work so
you know
um yeah I enjoy doing that for you like
uh I know doing your tour like is a big
deal because I feel like you're kind of
doing something that a lot of La artists
have had trouble doing yeah and that's
like doing like a national tour yeah you
know and I think like a lot of that is
just the result of like [__] the last 15
projects straight of just you know
building your monthly listeners and and
I think like uh
I have noticed like that for you because
I think we always look at a lot of
quote-unquote La rappers as having a
certain ceiling but I do feel like
you've done a good job of like starting
to break out of what that ceiling looks
like for sure
for sure like my goal my goal in the
culture and my contribution is to
is to bring something new to LA and when
I say newest you know
our culture and the way we operate out
here is like to chill hang and bang [__]
and it also spill over into the hustle
so a lot of people do the minimum and
expect the maximum and uh you know
another one of my things where branding
is perception and making it impossible
possible and seeing you know like where
other people don't see and you know it
is a market for us on a touring road but
you got to step out and build that [__]
up so my goal is to you know just show
[__] that's coming up after me
that yeah you could make millions
as a West Coast artist doing West Coast
[__] we got to just go open up these
markets that [__] with us so you know
you may go do a show
um I didn't have shows that I did like
when I did my very first tour bro that
[__] was it was humbling first of all
right but it didn't make me want to quit
it's like when I first got my first dope
sack like I had a quarter piece and it
took me forever to sell that [__] you
know what I'm saying but I kept going so
I didn't have shows where it's [__]
20 people there right you know I mean in
a 500 cap room right and I rocked it
like it was you know sold out yeah but
that [__] um
that should make a lot of people run and
hide from it because you putting
yourself out there and you know you
create this image of I'm already on and
I got all this [__] so the steps that
you got to take a lot of people put
their mind
to where this image is fake it till you
make it already got it so when it's time
to do this [__] it's like it don't mess
it don't mess with your brand so you
can't really grow but my whole thing is
to just you know let [__] know
what is money and touring we do gotta
market and like you could make M's like
independent and you don't need to
[__] go to a label and have this
whole fake [__] going on and hope that
you hit the lotto right because that's
really what it is you gotta if you're
gonna sign to a major you kind of got to
hit the lotto because you kind of need a
hit record to happen for sure
and even then
maybe you don't recoup and then and
you're F you're never really gonna
recoup because it's kind of set up
listen do you want to win some money
gotta stop the interview but listen
there's so many opportunities to gamble
to bet on your favorite sports to make
Sports more interesting NFL season is
over but it's all good because the
opportunities to win are just getting
started yeah look there's so many things
you can do we're talking about NCAA NBA
NHL UFC boxing there's Blackjack
tournaments so much money to get in on
and check this out y'all if you sign up
right now using the promo code bootleg
do it right now you can get a welcome
bonus up to a thousand dollars plus
you're gonna get a free hundred and
fifty thousand dollar March Madness
bracket contest entry that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
they could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP you think jokic is going to
win it you think Joel embiid is going to
win it Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas it's set up to never
recoup look the average artist
90 percent of [__] deals is like a
royalty deal even [__] that say they
got JVS this should be [__] fluff for
a headline
so it's like a uh on average it's 85-15
type [__] or 12 royalty right but what
they don't tell you is that when they
spend a million on you and you recoup
you could make five million but or let's
just let's break it down even smaller
they spent a hundred thousand on you
and you make two hundred thousand you
really only recoup thirty thousand
dollars right because you're only
recouping yeah it's it's pretty much
for every dollar that so let's say you
have a ten percent royalty deal right
just that's an even number so
essentially
every ten dollars that comes in out of a
hundred goes towards paying your balance
off right the rest of it they just put
it it just got free so it's like you're
not recouped but we made a shitload of
money that's right so for you to really
recoup off that hundred your music needs
to make a million if you're on a ten
percent rate exactly and that's how you
recoup and then you start getting a
royal teacher how much is how much
streams you really need to do to make a
million dollars off of a record or an
album it's it's a serious amount exactly
and it's like that's why you know people
complain about these deals and the deal
don't get restructured what they do is
they don't hesitate to give you more
money because it's like it's a great
deal for them it's a great business
[__] yeah exactly it's not like they
didn't make no money
you didn't you just didn't recoup but we
made money so oh man you got a problem
we love you we want to here's another
million dollars drop an album yeah here
goes it because we made a shitload of
money already
that should be happening with so many
artists that I know where they'll
complain but then they'll they'll take
the advance yeah because it's like all
right take the events because what they
complaining about they need money okay
cool here's money here goes some money
all right you better tour yeah we just
put a Band-Aid over some [__] that needs
Staples and stitches and now you got
more money to recoup you've done you've
dug your whole deeper with the label but
that there is something that
people I think have a uh
so if you aren't recouped it's not so I
think normal people think that when they
hear that that if you're not recouped
that you didn't make money no that you
are like in debt to the label right like
personal right like no like if the label
gives you a million dollars
and your music only makes a hundred
thousand dollars
now you might not be recouped through
your deal right but it's not like you're
moving around with a [__] nine
hundred thousand dollar debt over your
head right the label yeah because I
gonna write if they let that if they let
you go They're gonna write you off like
with with rock man it's your tax
write-off yeah we're Roc Nation they let
me go and it's like I think I'll [__]
owed them like eight hundred thousand
did you see what little Russell said
that like Roc Nation offered him like a
really bad deal
uh yeah yeah I saw that interview yeah
was that how was your deal no my
situation went nothing like that but you
know at the end of the day this is
business like in business people are
gonna do and get over with what they can
I'm saying and it's up to you to catch
up with it like
um
even with lawyers and [__] like these
lawyers are slick as a [__] and
a lot of times they all like like they
kind of work together yeah and like you
got to kind of really find your own like
entertainment lawyer that's kind of like
maybe not living in La for sure like
because or somebody that's fresh out of
college that's like somebody with you
you know right because they will try to
they will try to sneak [__] in like I
know how the situation to where
I worked out a deal and this
[__] telling me all right
everything is great I don't like this I
don't like this I'm gonna tell them this
but didn't tell me that he slept in
I need five percent out of this deal in
the contract you tell me everything else
but forget to and a lot of people get
[__] like that but I'll be on top of
everything so because it's like I could
just pay you for your hourly fee um yeah
but it's like a [__] they'll
Court you oh it's love bro I'm here for
you let you know everything and then
still sneak in some [__] under your nose
like all this [__] go on you know I mean
but you can't get mad at it it's the
games I think that I see well I noticed
that too with a lot of managers you know
on top of it managers shitty managers
will back though they'll force their
artists into a shitty record deal
because they don't got to recoup off the
advance they get their percentage
scot-free yeah I need to pay this rent
so they're getting their bread meanwhile
you're locked into a shitty deal and
you're not gonna recoup and it's like
what the manager got paid the lawyer got
paid right you know what I mean I see
that [__] happening all the time
like some of my homies are like their
[__] management will like be pushing
them to sign like shitty deals and I'm
like bro because I want it's a red flag
and managers like that that's how a lot
of managers think
I'm the coach I outlive the artist I'm
gonna have 30 more of you like the
[__] I didn't heard somebody
say I'm not gonna say who but close to
him [__] average artist lifestyle
lifespan is five years but that's really
not the case no more because rapping
turned into rock and roll right too
short damn near 60 and he's still the
[__] yeah he's almost 60 yes he like 55
56 how old is sugar-free sugar-free is
around the same thing 53 54 but it's
like rapping and turned into rock and
roll so it's it's no age limit but like
people
um
a bad management to tell you [__] like
that and then put this
idea in your head that you gotta rush
into these [__] up situations because
you only got a window you know what I
mean but if you're a brand you're gonna
be here forever rappers do got a [__]
expiration date but Brands don't right
uh are you pretty much self-managed now
or do you have management yeah because I
feel like it you could kind of you you
know you're one of the few artists I
feel like probably don't need a manager
you have good people around you you got
a great product yeah yeah yeah yeah
Empire like Gentry yeah Gentry my
project manager you know what I'm saying
and he's like
he's definitely one of the best like
this doing some groundbreaking I think
Gentry gonna be one of the people that
like changed the game in the future but
you know he assists me but as far as uh
management man I you know I do I'm a
mastermind like you know not to toot my
own horn but like I'm a hustler so it's
like I know that
the game is like it's really only 10 of
the music it's 90 of how you position
yourself how you set up your brand and
how you do all this and I was just
telling somebody the other day like
man I only need to do [__] 15
of what a major artist gotta do and I'm
getting the same money or more and I'll
do what I want and I feel like I could
like I feel great you know what I'm
saying I felt like I honestly felt like
like music turned into a job when I
signed yeah I mean and it just turned
into pressure because the the lights in
it and the perception of this [__] oh he
would Rock Nation and just like that
[__] [__] up a gang of relationships
with me because [__] is next to
me but not paying attention to what's
really going on just like the look of
[__] you know what I'm saying so like
independent is where it's at man like
people will sign for the wrong reasons
like you said it's the look it's the
like now I'm on here I get to go to the
brunch or I get you know it's like that
[__] is great and like shout out to that
you know but like
I don't think I think that your your
life is way more important than that
yeah your peace of mind your freedom
your flexibility all these things that
freedom is everything because I wanted
to quit when I said I was retiring I
really felt like that like [__] this I
know
I'm a cold [__] I could go make
millions anywhere I'm a hustler so it's
like like music had me jaded for a
minute and it like just being
independent I told gazi man I said bro
like
bro you gave me Freedom bro like
I respect you and lay you for that you
know what I'm saying so like you know
you got me
how do you like what are some of the
because I feel like the apparel business
obviously you got blue t-shirt
um but it seems like a very competitive
hard
like seeing the pop like because there's
just so many clothing brands and it's
like like what is like kind of some of
the uphill battles you have to go
through when it comes to the clothing
business I mean it's the same thing with
music like right now my like
I wouldn't even say struggle but
challenge right now it's just like
getting it whole infrastructure
everything tight because like I got a
product that's a [__] no-brainer
right when you walk up with this is a
blue t-shirt and that [__] fly
anybody in the [__] planet is gonna
have something to say about that you're
saying it's self-explanatory it's not
one of those things where I got
some letters and I gotta explain what
each letter mean and give you this long
drawn-out [__] it's just like oh that's
tight yeah the [__] the whole thing
behind this is perception and and my
perception my specific perception is
you could make the impossible possible
so if I say it's this that's what it is
and this time to make it happen and I
feel like a lot of people
in the world
or just just in life period business
need to understand that because if you
got a dope idea or if you got something
dope or something Cutting Edge
what is like 90 of my father's gonna
tell you that's a bad idea that's crazy
I always do that always [__] get a
job do this yep so that's pretty much
what blue t-shirt represent you know I
mean but you know without saying all
that just seeing it is [__] dope you
know I mean I was like the probably the
best thing I created bro I was gonna say
do you do you feel like because you know
you'll see guys like burn or YG kind of
scale their clothing lines to a certain
level are you starting to kind of like
maybe hit some of these trade shows like
there's magic and there's project and um
what's the other [__] this agenda yeah
you know all that kind of [__] is that
something that you're gonna yeah so the
next run or all that [__] I'm gonna be
their present you know what I mean so
the the same way I um been putting in
work with the music hitting the streets
we got everything lined up and organized
to do the exact same thing with blue
t-shirt while I could do it at the same
time because just from experience it was
like all right I'm working on music
right now it's no time for blue I'm
working on Blues you know there's
obviously no time to send me any clothes
exactly so the power of like trying to
reform though they sent me some stuff
reform is the [__] hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
Folks at Blue chew baby that's right A
lot of people keep asking me this
Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does and if
you don't believe me they'll give you a
whole month for free right now if you go
to bluetooth.com and use that promo code
bootleg that's bootry.com promo code
bootleg you get a month of blue chew for
free delivered to your [__] house all
you do is pay five dollars in shipping
what is Bluetooth you ask well let me
tell you it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable tablet but it is discreetly
delivered right to your doorstep no
awkward doctor's visits imagine going
and telling uh an old guy about your
dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you can do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month supply for free
and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
baked so much going on at Odd Socks uh
so many dope licenses man shout out to
uh they got Cheetos they got Jaws
[__] Oreos Cheech and Chong Naruto
WWE by the way WrestleMania is coming I
can't wait to see what dope WrestleMania
socks they do this year because last
year they knocked it out the parking Odd
Socks look the most comfortable socks in
the world they got The Odd Socks Basics
that you need on your feet uh all you
gotta do is go to oddsocksofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg at
checkout you'll save 20 off your total
order underwear socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview that's that is a [__] great
dude it's a great guy and you know he's
also good at karate
yeah he'll whoop your ass for sure yeah
I'm holding my own one no smoke would
you ever try to get because I know you
uh you know you own a boxing gym would
you ever try to get down with the uh
look Jujitsu or
um I was thinking about taking Jiu Jitsu
it was just like just the timing
of you know everything because when I
get involved I want to commit I don't
want to go to two classes and quit like
I actually want to get some like belts
and move up and think about Jujitsu is I
just don't know how much time I want to
spend rolling around with a dude on the
ground
right and getting this [__] kicked out
I've been getting ringworm or like
getting a [__] staph infection
because the [__] mats are dirty that
should be happening oh staff I heard
that when I was in a pen it was like the
staff [__] was big in the country at the
time right and [__] was
catching that [__] bro I was
man I was so spooked how long were you
locked up
um in total I did about six years what
was your longest like single like in
total of my life I did it about six
years a little over six years what was
the longest uh single bid
um three years and like six months jeez
yeah or four months three and four
something like that yeah
for you like
who's playing you in the movie Man you
were in prison you got so much crazy
[__] that's happened in your life if you
had to pick somebody to play you in a
movie who would it be
um man he probably ain't even um hit the
scene yet it's yourself yeah you just
play yourself I feel like I'd be maybe
in certain parts but
um I ain't really thought about it but I
think like with the movie [__] my goal
with that too is like I'll be studying
[__] like John Singleton and
Euless Brothers where they was taking
these super talented unknowns and popped
them off yeah so that's that's like my
goal in this [__] I'm not looking for
the big name like I know I
so I've been trying to get in it so I
didn't set with a lot of different
producers and a lot of different writers
and a lot of these dudes think the same
way some of these rappers think having a
gang of names tied to some [__] is gonna
make it dope like it's gonna get you
some eyeballs but is it gonna make great
product well think about uh who Uncle
Jerome the actor was or who Franklin
Saint the actor was before that show and
now they the [__] now they're [__]
lit right so that's my goal with that
Franklin states banging Lori Harvey
right now God bless him
I'm just saying uh okay so how many more
projects are you dropping this year the
big album is coming for sure at the end
of the year yeah big album fourth
quarter we're gonna do the um probably
just end it with a like Novo show or if
I could do something bigger than that
that'd be awesome I mean it's about time
to do the novo or do Palladium yeah yeah
yeah yeah I didn't have been having
offers to do them but the Roxy show was
special yeah and the like the Roxy like
I could have did the novo you could have
been so you got to do the Roxy first but
it's like it's for like tradition's sake
I feel like it's like I love the Roxy
and I wanted to just do like my one last
show
I mean so that could go down but yeah I
think um I'm pretty I got the Fonda
coming up you know I mean that's big
yeah so how many dates are you and
Richie doing uh 25. that's a lot man how
far east are you guys going we're going
all the way to Massachusetts Cambridge
Massachusetts I think that's far and
then Orlando Florida so Northeast and
Southeast that's lit yeah you think you
like like I do think like uh
you know having fans because I remember
living in Tampa
and at the height of My Crazy Life YG
came
and I was because you know I'm a West
Coast guy I'm from Phoenix yeah
so when YG came to Tampa this is like
when he was on fire fire and no one
cared because it was Florida so it was
like different right like people were
they loved like Rich Homie Quan and
boozy like people who wouldn't admit
necessarily people would have cared
about like that out here you know but I
do think it's like important like like
you said like you gotta go and build
those markets up fan by fans exactly so
I know a lot of these dates
um I'm putting myself up to the
challenge and building uh majority of
the dates over half of the dates is
no-brainers they're going to be sold out
right but
um my goal is to build the torrent so
you know I'm curious to see how Orlando
Florida go yeah I mean um
and however ago I'ma just keep hitting
the nail on the head until I build that
market out because once it's built then
you know that's that's that's extra dull
to the net at the or the gross at the
end of the year so you know that's my
goal what has been the most random like
uh place you've seen like fans just
really [__] with you
outside
[__] outside of the US outside of the US
yeah
Japan
Australia well Japan is not rent it's
West Coast they [__] are West Coast
[__] in Japan um Australia
London like I get DMS every [__] day
from overseas have you been to Japan yet
no do you think you'd be allowed to go
yeah for your record for sure I heard
it's just like it's like Canada no it's
not as bad but I heard it's like no I
should be good I've been out of [__]
prison for I got released in uh January
2014 almost 10 years so I should be good
man I ain't got nothing but some you
know traffic violations you gotta tap in
DJ Emin and head they got the [__]
all the Japan there's like this like
West Coast culture out there yeah and
they'd be bringing hella like do you
smoke one out there and got a bag yeah
yeah we definitely hitting that who's
your DJ steals okay my boy steals he did
he my DJ executive producer I'm my
executive producer yeah so like me and
stills like got this Synergy built like
yeah yeah you guys got such a chemistry
man yeah yeah yeah that's my boy like
because we like kind of like similar
person like everything he want and
trying to do like each of you have
regrettable tattoos for sure for sure
for sure you're physically inclined yeah
yeah yeah and the little Seasons you
know a little seasoned and and it's just
like we we both at the same point to
where it's like now or never and the
um our Now or Never isn't like the fame
necessarily but it's like them digits we
need to get to eight now he's got I saw
I just saw him in a AV or drop in an
album so yeah so shout out to steal
shout out to AV Steel's been putting in
that work yeah so we just we we both
built in real estate in this [__] and
helping each other I was gonna say like
when you drop that much music is it kind
of like
is that the way you look at it like the
more catalog I have
is it like compounding interest almost
yeah for sure and then you never know
which one is going to be which and then
also
you know the way I look at it like a lot
of artists that I fell in love with
um like in the beginning of the 2010
that era like the YouTube era a lot of
the artists that I became serious fans
of like Wiz currency yeah uh [__] uh
Wayne well Wayne before that gz
um French all these different artists
they had a shitload of content so you
know when I discovered them like it's
it's a lot of [__] for me to fall in
love with them and then like around the
time when I discover whiz and was like
damn this [__] is crazy them black and
yellow hit yeah and then all the other
[__] go up so you know I'm trying to
trying to get married everything else
comes up yeah I'm trying to mirror that
in my own way it's like okay with all
the catalog that I get let's say a song
Hit I'm not I'm not doing my career
based on a hit song because I know I can
make M's without a hit song so but if it
hit song do hit then guess what my
catalog go from whatever a month to a
million a month you know what I mean
yeah and then when they talking about
selling catalog [__] give me 80 million
dollars right are you uh do you feel
like because I do feel like I saw Russ
recently comment on this and Rush is
somebody who kind of blew up through a
lot of music videos but he just said
recently that
music videos aren't as important as they
used to be in terms of like the effect
of I guess the ROI you would get
definitely do you feel like that's the
case because I I know you still shoot
videos yeah that's a fact because like
let's say like my record keep killing
for example
keep killing if you look on YouTube it's
gonna look like the record is
but that [__] got like [__] 30 40
million streams total right you know
what I'm saying and it's not even close
to a million on YouTube you know what
I'm saying so
yeah I feel what he's saying I think in
this era like like YouTube and like this
the information error right so these
podcasts and all this [__] is the [__]
and like
I think YouTube is designed more for
[__] to get acquainted with
your brand at this point and how you
think and where you're it almost is like
a little extra like you know it's a it
it's if you're an independent artist
like you're probably not going to spend
the amount of money on music videos that
you might have three or four years ago
yeah for sure but it's something that
kind of just helps with the brand yeah
it definitely helps it's a commercial
you know I mean I think a song is a
commercial for the brand but
um
uh yes like this the information error
and that's like even with um with press
right because I I had a PR since the
jump and that that's what uh that's what
helped me get known before my music like
I was more known in my music you know I
mean and um
like with the the way that the game is
going like the pr run is not really it's
kind of becoming like dinosaur type [__]
like going to blogs and going to this
yeah I feel like paying a PR person if
you have like decent relationships a
waste of money now yeah it's like uh if
someone's trying to sell you on blog
placements that's a [__] red flag
yeah that's that's dinosaur [__] and
it's like
like it's the [__] podcasts are way
more you know important and valuable so
um
yeah bro like PR I think [__]
podcasts and all this different [__] is
way more important than a PR run at this
for sure would you uh would you ever do
your own podcast
um
not at this point maybe when I slow down
with music because with a podcast bro
like
you got to offer too many different
things of yourself unless you keep it
you know on one specific thing and it's
like it kind of steal from the the
Mystique of the music right you know
what I mean it's good money though it's
great money like if you I would
definitely recommend if you're an artist
and you can't figure out how to stream
or how to get people on your [__] like
do a [__] podcast bro like
that [__] is that [__] I know a lot of
people that make like a lot of artists
that got podcasts now and made more than
they ever made they got like an A.D old
projects running it up exactly so A.D
like A.D killing it I'm like super proud
of AD right now like that's like that's
dope because he a good dude so you know
he found his way so sort out El Rey with
the podcast big deal exactly yeah
um
your era let's say 2010 to 2020 who's
the Mount Rushmore La wrap 2010 to 2020
what's the Mount Rushmore five faces
give me five sure it's four but give me
five uh Kendrick nip
YG
um
[__]
damn
Kendrick knit YG Dom
uh
and like as far as like La where you
know they from LA
[__] G Perico I like it
it's a solid five
uh right after this gangster girls you
got another project ready to go or yeah
I got another project coming I got the
click tape coming um
um it's a it's another project by me but
it's it's just more focus on
um
you know artists that I like out here
and because I don't do a lot of features
right I mean um
this is a
uh
[__] um
damn I lost my train you were saying
that you're focused on the oh yeah click
type so click tape just artists that I
like and um you know people that I would
like to do music with and then other
artists that I'm introducing you know
under the uh Enterprise
umbrella like my homie two Milli uh
um [__] uh Rock G4
um mofego well mofego not really uh
Enterprise click but I [__] with him
heavy dope about a uh Ohio and you know
different people that I always wanted to
do music with but you know on my
projects it's like my shit's so specific
to the lifestyle and what I do
like I don't sometimes I just feel like
people can't add value to that even if
they give me a hard-ass verse even if
you're like super like if you turn down
big big features because you just didn't
see like yeah I got a lot of big
features that was supposed to go on
projects but it was like
it's like why what do you adding to the
project yeah now if like as far as like
monetary game like it definitely add
that so you know we're gonna just start
adding that slash with these click tapes
you know there it is man we'll look the
new gangster girls drops Friday Thursday
night Thursday night gangster grills 310
G Perico DJ Drama
AKA number one that's me baby when's the
tour start
March 30th we start in Brooklyn we start
in Brooklyn then we hit Massachusetts
then Orlando
and uh then back this way yeah we're
getting we're getting all over the place
after that it's the tour is like this
are you excited hell yeah I'm excited
I'm super excited because I love when I
get on stage and just bump into
[__] like bro somebody hit me
the other night
and and I felt him he was like bro I was
about to commit suicide and it's a real
[__] like a gangster [__] bro I was
thinking about committing suicide dog
and like just listening to your music
and then because you know I speak on a
lot of [__] that I go through and the
the Troubles of the [__] like it's like
therapy for me but he like man I
listened to it then looked at you bro
and was like I didn't do it you know
what I'm saying so but then as other
people walk up to me man I I got through
college I'm a [__] like psychiat or
whatever the [__] you know what I'm
saying with your music so just seeing
different walks of life School teachers
[__] other just gangster [__] and
kids trying to build [__] so you know
being able to see them and touch them
and feel that energy bro and it's
nothing like it that's fire man well
listen Perico appreciate you pulling up
new album on the way mixtape Gangsta
grills
Enterprise
click no more jewelry man you got enough
it's a giant chain I got a few other
pieces on the way I bet you do Jesus
Christ all right you got to get a bigger
Truman for this [__] boom